breaking overnight the fda has now
officially authorized a third vaccine
dose for people who have compromised
immune systems or received an organ
transplant right now the booster is only
for those who got the pfizer or moderna
vaccines the news comes as at a
harrowing moment in texas where many
hospitals are overwhelmed with
unvaccinated people more than 90 percent
of icu beds across the state are full
and it's getting worse every day janet
chameleon is in houston now with more
janet what's the situation there
dana good morning to you we are being
told that some patients are having to
wait days in the emergency room just to
get a spot in the icu this morning some
10 000 texans are hospitalized with
covet and about 50 hospitals across the
state say they have no room at all in
intensive care
this morning alarming numbers out of the
houston area
just 27 icu beds are available for a
region of more than six and a half
million people we're back in the throes
of things as if we were in another you
know wave of the pandemic before the
vaccination roll out dr kunal shama is
chief of emergency services at lbj
hospital in houston overflow tents have
been built here to manage the
overwhelming surge of patients the icus
are full every bed is accounted for and
in fact we have patients waiting in our
emergency center for icu beds to open up
are they waiting a couple hours or how
long some wait hours some wait days to
be to be frank
staffing shortages are adding to the
weight dallas parkland hospital one of
the nation's largest says it needs 500
more nurses
and has had to send some pregnant
patients to other hospitals more than 10
thousand texans are hospitalized with
covid this week including 54 year old
tim cotto he was in the hospital needing
some support on oxygen and then all of a
sudden things just drastically changed
for him tracy cotto says her husband was
intubated at a small local hospital but
as his condition worsened doctors said
he needed to go to one with an icu she
says they couldn't find one that would
take him as a transfer patient with
their insurance in texas
then from outside his hospital room a
plea on social media please don't let my
husband die because we can't get him the
help that he needs we must buy him icu
bed today in the houston area an icu bed
did open and tim was transferred a few
days later tracy says he has no
pre-existing conditions but wouldn't say
if he was vaccinated she did say
his condition is dire what is behind
your reasons for optimism right now i
don't really have a choice to think
anything else because i have four kids
and they are looking at me to try to
lead them and to get through this it's
so terrifying and i just want to help
but there's nothing i can do
texas is a state of about 30 million
people according to the state health
department there are only 329 icu beds
available school is starting here on
thursday a county judge ordered a mask
mandate for the schools following dallas
and austin doing the same that is in
defiance of the governor's ban on mask
mandates vlad all right janet thank you
very much